- [Instructor] Let's say
that we have some country,
let's call it Utenslandia,
that can only produce
one of two goods or some
combination of them.
So it can produces forks,
or it could produce spoons.
And so this axis is the quantity forks,
this axis is the quantity of spoons
and let's say that if it
puts all of its energy
into forks, well it would
produce that many forks
and no spoons, and but
then if tried to focus
some of its energy, some
of its resources on spoons,
well then it would produce fewer forks
and then the more spoons it produces,
it will produce fewer and fewer forks
all the way to the point that
if it only focused on spoons,
well it could produce that many
but then it would produce no forks.
What this curve is, and we touched on it
on other videos, this is the
production possibilities curve
for our country of Utenslandia
that makes utensils
and obviously, most countries
are much more complex,
they don't only produce some
combination of two things
but this helps us, this is a nice model
for understanding what
countries might be capable of.
Now one way to understand this production
possibilities curve is it shows
what can be efficiently
produced by this country.
If it efficiently utilized
all of its resources,
then it will produce some
combination of forks and spoons
that sit on the production
possibilities curve.
So this point right over here,
this combination of spoons which would be
that many spoons and that many forks,
this combination over here,
this would be efficient.
That point x would be
an efficient production for Utenslandia.
So at this point right over
here, let's call that point y.
Now what happens if Utenslandia goes
into some type of recession.
For whatever reason, it's
not able to use its resources
as efficiently, and we're
talking about resources,
we're talking about
land, we're talking about
maybe its factories, we're talking about
the materials it has, maybe its labor,
well on that situation, let's say
it was operating efficiently here
but then the recession happens
and so it then it
operates right over here,
let's call this point right over here z,
this would be an inefficient
use of its resources,
sitting behind the production
possibilities curve.
So this is inefficient, just like that.
And so one question you might have
is well what about points that are beyond
the production possibilities curve
like point, let's just call
that point a right over there.
What about that point?
Well, unless you have more inputs,
unless you have more land, more capital,
more labor, if you don't
change the resources here,
this is actually going to be
an unattainable point for Utenslandia.
But let's say you really wanna reach it,
how can that happen?
Well, you can actually have investment
or you could have more land or more labor.
So let's think about that scenario.
So let me draw the two axes.
So that's my fork axis,
that's the quantity of forks
that Utenslandia will produce in the year.
This will be the spoon
axis, right over there.
And let's draw our original
production possibilities curve.
So I'll try to make it look pretty similar
to what we had before.
So that's our original
production possibilities curve.
Another way of thinking about it
is it's showing the trade off
between producing forks and spoons.
You can actually think about
what is the opportunity cost of producing
an incremental spoon in terms of forks.
How many forks do you have to trade off
because remember,
there's scarcity at play.
You don't have an infinite amount of metal
to produce things with, an
infinite amount of labor,
an infinite amount of factories.
But let's say Utenslandia,
they are able to get
some more land on which
to build factories,
maybe they build some more factories
so capital goes up, maybe some people
migrate to Utenslandia.
So in that situation,
you would have growth
and your production possibilities curve
would actually shift outward.
So here, we are showing,
let me make it a little bit,
we are showing a
situation right over here,
this is still a production
possibilities curve
but we're showing what
happens when you have growth.
And once again, what are
the drivers of growth?
Well this could be the amount
of land that you have goes up.
The amount of capital
that you have goes up.
Capital could be things like factories,
it could be machinery,
you could have people, more
people are able to help produce
the spoons or forks.
You could just have better technology
for producing spoons and forks.
Sometimes people will even
talk about entrepreneurial spirit,
that people are able to
figure out better ways
of combining these resources
so that you could produce
more spoons or forks.
But let's imagine now the other scenario.
Let's imagine a scenario where Utenslandia
gets into a war with Platelandia.
And Platelandia sends their bombers in
and starts destroying some of
the factories of Utenslandia
and so what will happen in that situation?
So before the war, this is that production
possibilities curve for Utenslandia.
But now, because of the
war, maybe Platelandia
is able to take some
land from Utenslandia,
maybe it's able to destroy
some of the factories
and other forms of capital,
maybe people flee Utenslandia
so there's less labor.
And maybe for whatever reason,
they can support less technology
or they forget how to use
some of their technology
'cause the war is so long and protracted.
Well in that situation, your
PPC, you would see contraction.
And contraction, I could depict it,
let me shift my PPC, my
production possibilities curve
inward just like this.
So this is a situation where
we are seeing contraction.
So big picture here, your
production possibilities curve
is exactly what it says it is.
It shows what can a, what
is the potential combination
of, in this case, goods
that this nation can produce
and if you're sitting on the curve,
it shows that that nation, that country
is efficiently using its resources.
If you're sitting within the curve,
it's inefficiently using its resources.
And if you're on the right of the curve
or beyond the curve,
well that's a situation
where if you don't change the inputs,
all else equal, this would
actually be unattainable.
The way that you actually
do attain, get to points
beyond the curve, is by
shifting the curve itself.
By having more land,
more capital, more labor
or more technology which we
see in this middle scenario.